hey everybody it's gary vaynerchuk and
i'm here with the incredible hope tates
and shelley's alice uh we have another
episode
episode of capitalized on you uh we're
excited to be here it's a big day for
our thematics
of this show i'll let uh hope get into
that in a little bit
and we're gonna we're gonna spend this
half hour kind of talking about the
state of the union
of what is going on in uh our
perspectives
on this world now i will let the much
more accomplished and beautiful
co-hosts introduced themselves ladies
i hope all you well so i'm hope tates
thanks gary it's always a pleasure
the state of the world is absolutely
changing at a rapid pace
i am thrilled to be here today uh we
have a
female gonna be a vice president um last
time we talked about who should have
been on the
on the bill uh and we all should have
said rbg
i formed a company and used the symbol
for after
rbg this is also a great day for women
in so many ways
um in all of the walking that we have
walking
each and every day not just one day a
year um
thrilled to talk later today about what
we're do what i'm doing
to further the move for equality and how
you can capitalize on yourself
um shelley hey i'm charles ceo of the
female quotient i'm actually wearing my
t-shirt
i have a reason to be happy hope is
going to talk about why today
not only is giving tuesday but why
diversifying or
delisting is so incredibly important so
big smile
uh on my face and you know as hope said
it's not just about talking what we need
to do it's about walking it's about
creating the action steps necessary
i am the ceo of the female quotient
advancing women advancing equality
and as we always say we are better
together so so happy to be here with
garyvee and hope
for everybody who's tuning in for the
first time um the three of us are
friends
uh we have uh admiration society and we
we really think that money is wildly
misunderstood
you know and i think we all have our own
takes i think a lot of people that
follow me know that
i'm just trying to get people to not
make money the scoring card of life
because i just think it'll lead to a lot
more happiness um i've known hope
because we've sat on nonprofit
boards together we've been friends a
long time and i mean i know
i just have always been so attracted
long before it became
cool a decade plus ago of her points of
view on just like
how many women i'll never forget the
first time we talked about it how many
women don't know how to manage their
money and i laughed
and and we were just getting to know
each other and i was always curious if
she understood why i snickered
because my brain went most humans don't
know how to manage
98 of the guys i know don't know how to
manage their money and so
just a really exciting part and shelly
has been one of the great champions
of female executives so i think i'm
going to let these two ladies speak
quite a bit here but i wanted to
contextualize for everybody since we
haven't done a lot of these episodes
this is about
really taking control of your life in
the in the lane
of money i think people you know sex
money these are things america
and really the rest of the world
struggle with talking about
this you know there's a lot that we
could talk about but this is
in the financial lane um
and uh and we and we like to go macro
and we're about to i know with
some of the things that hope's going to
speak to but i also want to make sure
before we get out of here we go
super micro and make it practical that
was a big theme of the last episode i
was reading the comments
and i see all your comments right now
for everybody who's watching on their
platform of social choice
of how to make it tangible day-to-day
because the three of us
if we get rolling we can get very in the
clouds and so let's play on both sides
hope take it away with some information
well yeah so hope
one second before you go i want to
comment on something gary said
it's not just that we don't know how to
manage our money as women
we are afraid to ask what we don't know
and so
that is all about confidence and not
being afraid
to ask so hope take it from there so i
shelly i think that's a huge point it's
it's it's about fear factor
but as i said before managing your money
is not calculus it's a b c
it's it's adding it's not that difficult
and it's asking other people for help
and surrounding yourself by your own
personal board of directors
that can help advise you we do gary we
need to make very tangible and the
reason we have our guest chrissy today
is she's somebody that i have mentored
helped her through her career
helped her build up her own equity
helped her
understand and we're using this as an
example of what we can do
and keep tossing down the rope to
explain
money management we're going to do
another episode and actually have
an hr head and an episode that we're
going to actually have a
formal money manager who can talk about
asset allocation
and how to move your savings but that's
our whole goal is to lift you
guys up with specific areas that we can
be helpful in
i want to add one little context point i
have a client meeting that i can't get
out of in 16 minutes so at some point
i will just disappear that is not
because i am rude that is not because i
don't want to be here but i want the
audience to know that
and i know that you two will continue
the show um
can we can we talk for a second about
the incredible announcement that kind of
came across
today um i you know obviously hope i
think with your career you have a lot
more context on this
nasdaq made a substantial announcement i
think earlier today or maybe last night
depending on when i saw it
um can you go into that and it's
important
so adina friedman who is an absolute
pioneer ceo of nasdaq announced
that she's actually going to recommend
d-listing companies
that don't have a female person on the
board
and a person of an under
underrepresented group
that is an amazing stride to change why
change happens at the board it happens
at the top it goes down to the c-suite
and it permeates through the rest of the
human capital of the organization
nasdaq is walking the walk adina is
there that's why i chose to list my
recent public company on nasdaq
it is an amazing thing and it again it's
tone from the top
that has changed for all diversity and
for all women
hey but you know i also want to add that
you know people talk about quotas and
they say well is this a quota
and one of the things that i have never
want to be i don't want to be a quota
don't hire me because you need to fill
a seat because you're supposed to hire
me because i make the table better and i
think that that is really
what this is doing is understanding that
diversity
is good for business diversity is good
for bottom line
and by mandating it from the nasdaq
you know level not from the ceo level
but from the board level
so that we can ensure we have the best
table with
the best people at the table this is a
really
important move forward let me talk about
the mandate real quick
in a way it's funny as the white guy in
this conversation
the majority of my conversations with my
friends by the way
sometimes women as well sometimes
minority as well around mandates
and quotas because we've done mandated
in quotas in europe and the us for many
years
to spectacular failure because it's
optics
i have literally never ever had a
conversation around this issue
and especially the last call it the
metoo black lives matter era of business
i've literally explained to everybody
that
this do not take this out of any other
context
if you're a good person and you want to
be you know because i've watched so many
people in the last four years
do things for businesses that is them
being an activist
but it's actually bad for the business i
literally when i talk to
all these different groups and we i talk
about this a lot you two know me well
and know like
when i get together i like to talk about
real stuff more like it's
always important and macro and
foundational i just
explained to them i'm like this is like
so good
because context is everything and
if you don't value context you're gonna
be extremely vulnerable
and one of the great ways to be great at
context is different experiences
now that could be income level that can
be
race gender it could be a million
different things and then i reminded
somebody
who said man mandates are bad and i knew
the person really well and i said
maybe but i would argue that the things
that you used to complain to me about
that your parents
mandated you to do in your teens are now
the things you're telling the whole
world that even though you hated it at
the time it ended up being the best
thing
one could argue that mandates today
seem off or this or that or
because you're looking at it from a
business and you as a human you like it
you like it as a human but as a business
person you're like but if rick
thompson's the best person i don't want
to
hire hope tates for that board i'm like
you may believe that today
but could this become something in 20
years when you see all the data play out
you're like [ __ ]
this was way better yeah sometimes you
just need a little push
because if we wait and watch we know
that legacy will run faster than reality
this is just making it happen and once
we do
flip the balance and change the table
and reorganize it a little bit
it will become the new normal i think
that's really what we need to do it's
just a little bit
william jordan in facebook says seems
like demolition
of man's society and it's funny when i
hear that
i i a can
i i can understand with compassion
sympathy and empathy almost everything
so i can understand how that sentence
could be put out by will jordan i don't
think
i'm not this you know i'm i'm socially
liberal but i'm not like
so like you're a terrible person my
answer to most of my friends is
not if you're good you know one of the
things i always
am fascinated by is anything that
peop presidential elections i'm ruined
as an entrepreneur one way or the other
i've heard it for
25 years of my life i laugh because i go
if you think the president is the
variable of you being
successful in business you are a losing
player that is my honest opinion
i have made money with bill clinton and
with george bush
and barack obama and with donald trump
and i will with joe biden
and then sarah thompson and ricky magoo
and guardagolas
because i'm a [ __ ] winner people look
for excuses
so so i think people totally look for
excuses and they also
look for the same players all the time
gary one of the things about this thing
this mandate
is that it's it's what it's going to do
is bring out some of the unsungs
because everybody's going to the same
pool you
bet on people that don't necessarily
have the track record
or the background that's right because
because hope because i'm 45
and even though i'm a white dude i went
to mount ida college everybody
women black white everybody told me i
was a loser
everybody i didn't have the pedigree
even when i met you
hope this is not from you you know what
i met you hope and
i'm just going back to that era of like
the you know
a decade ago i
today i feel more comfortable in my lack
of education but i'd be lying
if i didn't say when i was making the
transition in the in the 2005 to 2010
era
and i was in rarified air that i knew
that people immediately thought less of
me because i didn't go to warren
or yale or stanford or harv i lived in
it i lived in it
and so that happens all the time so for
me the hypocrisy
would be insane like i only listen you
know this hope
i bet the other way i tend to i tend to
be more concerned of people that have
had the easy path because i think
business takes punching in the face and
that's and so
and the problem is the headhunters have
gone all the same people with the same
pedigree
and the unsungs and the and the women
with their heads down
and the woman that are doing great great
things these are the ones that are going
to get exposed now this is an amazing
day
i think and it is everything you have
preached for the last 10 years to me
oh by the way and i apologize i'm going
to bounce out oh by the way because i
want this last point and
take it away it's also going to lead to
white males that don't go to good
schools
having more opportunity when we open our
hearts it opens to everybody
you know we act as if like this doesn't
happen it happens in every direction
i just think i just think context is
imperative shall we
yeah i just want to say before you
bounce it's this is why this show is
called capitalize
on you and you just said gary you're
[ __ ] great
and it is about believing in yourself
and not waiting for someone else to make
your bed
my girlfriend charlotte beers says you
know i'd rather be in charge and
i'd rather be in charge and if i started
my own business
and capitalized on myself because who's
to say that
the way i lead is wrong i i think the
way i lead
is great and it's creating a new way of
leadership
and you use that word empathy and
compassion and resilience
and we can have that as leaders we can
make our own bed the way we want to make
it and by the way
and by the way the business of the bill
the business results are going to speak
for themselves
two of the great business creators in
the last 40 years in meg whitman
right and katzenberg got together to
build quality it's a
massive failure this is what i love
about business after you get through all
this i didn't know anything about
diversity and inclusion when i was in
entrepreneur land pre
vaynermedia because it didn't cross my
mind to hire anybody but the person that
would help us win because we're trying
to [ __ ] win out here
you know but even when even when you
have the pedigree there's a great man
and woman combo team
that have one of them will have one of
the great failures of this era with
quibby
like business will figure itself out if
you're winning
you're winning and if you you can't win
you won't win but it's also
gary the point and the point you've
always said it's
about the and about understanding that
it's not linear
right so how you when you when you have
a epic failure or you have a
a major stub in the road how do you keep
walking
how do you get up how do you actually
use it i mean i actually love investing
in people that have failed before
because
they have a certain sense of grit that
they do not want to go down that rabbit
hole again
right it's it is it is the per the
perfect resume
the 4-0 kid that you don't want to hire
actually
because they haven't dealt with it
before leadership is not in a textbook
period exclamation point you know it's
street fighters and those that have
failed are the ones that succeed
because you learn from those failures
and you certainly don't do them again
let's go narrow before i leave because i
love learning from you two as well and
so i'll just set it up what's like a
really wild
practical reality to somebody who's
listening right now i get this dm a lot
and i don't
you know i go into my answers i want to
get some different answers
what is the person that has two thousand
dollars in savings
think about in today's world like you
know i i go into like go garage sailing
and flipping and sports
because i think it's a low base and i
want them to get high upside
but you know the stock market other
things you're thinking about
or by the way feel free because i set it
up this way take it a completely
different place
but just down to the street level you
know under 2k in savings but want to put
that into working willing
to have some risk tolerance what comes
to mind when i set it up that way
so i'll go first on this one so the
first thing is a
that is that two thousand dollars that
they don't need it
right so that the risk tolerance is high
right because
it do they need it do is it there as a
nest egg to help pay for rent if they
lose their job
then you're not going to take that risk
factor in investing it
right the stock market has become much
more liquid
you can buy smaller units but if you
understand what that dollar amount is
and understand what how
are you willing to lose it all or do you
need it is that part of what you need to
back up your
your rent payment etc so i have two very
different ways of of looking
at it i also said how do you figure out
how to make extra money in your life
right you do it get gary garage sales
and
and buying and selling things i know so
many
people that are selling uh apparel on
poshmark and other sites
like like go and capitalize on other
ways you can make money
double time your your efforts then that
2000 maybe becomes 4 000
and maybe you're willing to take more
risks with the two than the other two
and that's a better way of looking at
how you're looking at your portfolio in
your
in your life so i i always figure out
other ways to keep making money
right you you know i love your garage
sale stuff but poshmark and thinking
but what what about saving money cutting
out subscriptions that you actually
do not use right so that also gives you
more to your two thousand dollars
then you're willing to take more risk
with that money
that's the way i look fine i agree i
mean i just did that i took
all of the clothes that have been
sitting in my closet for over a year
that don't fit me and i sold them all
and that money that i made
i put back into investing and i invest
in
um women around the globe that are doing
remarkable things that as
you know hope you said are unsung heroes
that you know two thousand dollars goes
a long way to you know them becoming
champions and they pay it forward with
generosity so
it builds and match you know what's
funny about the scrappy
like one of the reasons i continue to
like
ebay is it's an honest market because
it's a two-way market like one of
i feel like all you really have to do
when you're in business is to figure out
how to bring so much value to the thing
on the other side
and then figure out how to get what you
need for whatever your ambitions are
after that and what i really like about
um the poshmark the ebay thing the
whether you're in the high end and you
have fancy bags and dresses or
you're on the low end you're what's
amazing about it is you're actually
learning a skill set that is
wildly important i i've gone on to be
super good at angel investing in stock
market investing
out of just being blindly
consumer-centric i don't know anything
else i don't know how to read
even the things that would be
standardized before you make an
investment i don't care
i just spent all my time realizing what
the end consumer cares about
and as long as they have enough cash to
get through to
realize that value profit as long as i
believe in the person running the
company
and it has that stability and that has
worked out tremendously well
when you're in that level of that level
of finance and you decide to learn how
to sell you're learning how to
buy sell market trade and you don't even
realize you're picking up on nuances
that will play out in your life later on
well and gary
i just want to add choice to that
equation because it makes you focus and
get rid of the junk in the trunk
and and focus you know because we're
hoarders and so it's just such a great
way to get rid of the
the [ __ ] and focus on the things that
matter but you're also going to gary
you're also going to learn when you're
doing that and you're operating you're
understanding the consumer
you're actually might even find a stock
that you actually think is going to do
much better
right because you see look what etsy has
done during covid right you're going to
see those
actions what marketplaces have done
right and and you're going to come up
with ideas
as well so you're you it's not just
reading the details of all financial
it's really understanding where the [ __ ]
is going
on on the consumer you're so good at
that
that's anticipating that and you can
invest that way in different ways
so you know my desire on this whole show
is to keep empowering and you're right
help the person with two thousand
dollars but also help them figure out
how they can put more money in their own
wallet
how they can also put money in their
wallet through their careers
and and get promotions and ask for more
and then you know and then
be where we are which is own your own
business and then
keep keep controlling what the rest of
that landscape looks like
emil kay in facebook says
why do we start with how i do with 2k he
goes nothing it's irrelevant i raised a
million dollars from two sources twice
thank you
uh seth for putting this on the screen
if you're watching you know this is an
interesting point
you know and hope you can probably speak
to this definitely more than i can and
shelly i don't know where you sit on
this but i'm fascinated
by how much money is being printed right
you know jesus there's a lot of money
out there floating around
um and when you start getting a little
more educated once it goes off the gold
standard in the seminary and you can
start
really putting pieces together i'm sure
it gets people excited about blockchain
and other things that nature but
i think emile makes a very good point
which is you know i
and you know this hope i don't love
raising capital it's not like an
enjoyment for me
but but but i do think it should be
mentioned
to this audience that we hear about
raising capital in the millions
there's a scenario with as much money
that's running around whether it's a
great uncle
or whether it's an employee a co-worker
in your current job
the level of practicality of raising 25
to 50 000
today is just so different than it was
30 years ago
and it's probably a worthwhile
conversation we i would argue and ladies
appease me here or or debate this and
get back to me
i think a conversation of the micro
fundraising could be really powerful
what if you just need to raise 25 000 i
haven't even i've never even really
thought about this which is why i'm
excited right now
that could be something that could bring
a ton of people value thoughts i
so i love that idea because i think but
again what's the right amount to raise
right sometimes you people raise too
much they dilute their own
they dilute their ownership and at the
end of the day maybe they have a great
company but they don't own that much
so not only what's the right amount to
raise
right so what what's your verse your
burn rate and then if you're raising a
small amount
how do you do that in the most effective
manner
right without somebody uh came to me and
said
you know i realized when i was raising
my seed seed round
that uh my family have had us no money
and i have no friends
it was pretty [ __ ] like i couldn't
raise my so how do you raise that
smaller amount when you don't have that
network
i think it would be a great topic and i
think we should do that and there's
crowdfunding and there are other ways to
do it but
don't raise too much if you over raise
you're going to delude yourself and we
should talk about that as well
we should also talk about what james
does is saying it goes
it it's not irrelevant my savings have
never seen 2000.
the issue for me isn't necessarily
growing mass quantities of cash it's
budgeting while
small to see how money moves to start
with and and he's right i think you know
what's so you know it's funny i posted
something yesterday i was like look i
never think i'm right
i i really don't i think i'm sharing
what has been right for me
i'm trying to over share contextualize
it and do it on all platforms
so that everybody who's listening right
now can take the things
that match them can leave the things
that don't it's one big game of
self-awareness
i would never recommend how i decided to
live my life i wanted
to spend the first 12 years building a
business for my parents because that was
what was in my soul
that that creates resentment to be very
frank for everybody who's confused or
not confused
that that's a real good path to build
something massively for
your parents and be 35 and not have a
whole lot of finances that leads to
resentment
i had the emotional stomach and
immigrant circumstances to be super cool
with it i've had people hit me up saying
gary you inspired me
i'm like working in my dad's store you
know i hate my dad i'm like
here's why you need to understand that
we were different
angles and i think the the key for this
show knowing that we have people that
have
seven figures on their in their bank or
in their stock market portfolio on this
show
and people that have seven dollars of
debt um
is contextualizing and taking pieces of
the conversation
and building on top of them yep and i
think we have to answer to all different
because needs are different but some of
the fundamentals
are the same right you know you and i
talked about the
beginning of covid right counting your
bananas right
making sure you have and it doesn't make
a difference if you have that much to
begin with
it can evaporate so how do we think
about that how can we help you
on all different kinds of levels and
then how do we help you capitalize on
what you have
you're going okay we're going to bring
in chrissy now
uh because we have an amazing we have an
amazing guest today
uh speaker
[Applause]
is not only the vp of strategic
initiatives at draftking
but has been a mentee of mine for a long
time is a remarkable
uh young lady who has risen up in her
career
and has literally built her board of
direct personal board of directors to
lift herself up
and we thought she'd be a great person
to help and give advice and and
talk and ask us questions so that
you guys can get what you need and we
can be more helpful
but before you do that though chrissy i
just want to ask you one key question
and this i hope it doesn't embarrass you
hope
um but what is the best thing
you know when we talk about hoping your
mentor what was the
the most stand out thing that you
learned from hope
gosh there's so many and i'm i'm
picturing these conversations and i've
literally been like on my phone
walking in the streets in new york with
hope just like telling me like it
telling me how it is and expl telling me
exactly what i know
in my gut i think she just cuts to the
chase um
and and one of the real things and
that's why i'm excited to be on
capitalize
on you is um one of the things hope has
really coached me on the last few years
is is really focusing on
my own owning my own wallet and moving
more towards equity-based compensation
um obviously you have to make sure from
a cash perspective you're covering your
expenses
but you know that's where that notion of
ownership is really where
um you start to have a game change in
terms of
your personal finances and that's
something she's really pushed me towards
you're very sweet uh unfortunately as
most people know i tell people not
necessarily what they want to hear but
what they need to hear
yeah because i believe that you know
hearing the truth is much
as painful as it is in the up front
helps you in the long run
because again this is about how do we
build your wallet how do we
how do we get you to own your own
business how do you
how do we get you to the top because
once you're at the top that's where all
the change can then happen
yeah yeah and i'd love to to flip the
mic on you guys
um i think uh you know one of the things
i think is really interesting is
as we talk about so gary was talking a
lot about how do you make this really
tangible for people which i think is
super important
um i think one of the themes both of you
have in your careers is ownership
whether it's as an entrepreneur as an
investor
um why has that been an important piece
for
each of you as you capitalize on
yourself
hope you go so i believe you
owning your own destiny is hugely
important
so that i can make the hiring decisions
i can make the
the chain look down under what diversity
looks like
i believe that i can make the choice i
joked i did a podcast once and i
somebody was surprised when i said i'm
married 30 years
but my husband has never seen my
american express bill
um it is about controlling your own
life and your own destiny um and
not somebody telling you what you should
or shouldn't do
um i think it's great to get advice i've
had amazing mentors myself that have
helped
guide me and lift me up but i love the
control factor
of how i can see the tone from the top
i believe that you hire good people that
hire good people
and that builds a chain down and i think
that chain
looks better being more diverse and
and also giving the hope that you're
there is aspiration
that they're going to rise up yeah for
me you know i
i have two two american addresses one
that you know my my husband sees in one
that he doesn't
and then my my business one so just
saying uh
control is is a good thing i think for
me i just was tired of following the
rules that didn't make any sense to me
and that's how i got my nickname
chief troublemaker i wanted to break the
rules and create new ones and i wanted
it to go my way and i wanted to be right
and i was tired of being
the exception oh we're making an
exception for no
i want to create the new rules the new
norm and
and make the exception the new norm and
from
from being told so many times that i
wasn't right or it wasn't the right
time or that's not the way it's done
i got sick of that and decided to start
my own company so that i could be right
and i could control my own destiny i
could write my own rules and i could
create a culture
that i could thrive in and knowing that
if i created a culture that i could
thrive in
it would be a culture that everyone
would be able to
bring themselves um and thrive in in the
workplace and that's what i did
chrissy i'm going to add one other thing
yeah i don't think that i don't think
that question would ever be asked to a
guy
so a lot of the things that and the
businesses when i started one of the
first female
founded hedge funds in 1995 when i
formed a queen
i mean nobody would ask the question of
why is a guy doing that
it is it you know why shouldn't a woman
do that
right all i am doing is is many of the
things that my
guy friends mentors etc have done before
me
but now i'm doing it as a woman and i'm
showing other women that you can do it
yeah and by the way you can do it you
could do it your way
and that could become the right way
well one thing is i was listening
earlier off off stage
in the virtual sense uh as you guys were
talking about the
the nasdaq announcement this morning um
of looking to diversify boards um
hope this actually reminds me of
something i previously shelly how to
start up with coach k the duke
basketball coach
which is how hope and i met um and one
of the things he talks about with
uh usa basketball which is uh he ran for
for over a decade um is the notion of
having standards not
rules and even the nasdaq um
announcement like flipping it so it's
not a rule or a mandate but it's a
standard
that nasdaq is setting for its its group
of companies or shelley as you think
about
you know chief troublemaker you're
setting a standard for your for your
company um it's an i always think back
to it of
rather than say hey we're gonna set
these rules so there's certain numbers
of certain people it's no we're
elevating the standard and it's what
gary was talking about of
you're going to hire the best people and
you're going to set a really high
standard
and you know diversity wins in that
instance
so i think i think that's right because
unfortunately when you set
hard number rules and we've seen some of
those rules in europe as gary was
alluding to earlier they backfire right
let's get the rate people to the table
let's pull them up
let's find them let's say this this is
what the gold standard
looks like and should look like and
others will fall
i that it you know it lead by example
yeah
and hope you were mentioning earlier um
you know that the population of public
board members is a it's a pretty small
pool that
uh or pond that that companies fish from
right now um
tell me a little bit about your
experience you know as a public company
board member
um and certainly with a qui as well
which you you just launched
um you know some of the responsibilities
you know that do start at the top and
kind of how they trickle into an
organization
so i've been very fortunate to be a
public company board member for 10 plus
years i've chaired every committee
taken multiple companies public taking
companies
private um it is setting that the board
has to
the job is to set the tone from the top
the board's number one job is to hire
and fire the ceo
right but that sets the tone and that
sets the tone
down the entire c-suite and it sets the
tone down to the entire workforce
what i have always wanted to do and
d e and i and esg moving so much into
that conversation now
in the board room is it's not just check
the box exercises
right it's how does the board care and
show that they care
about mission and vision and human
capital
and those are all things that are
creating much longer
term value to all stakeholders both
shareholders internally in the company
and the outside long-term shareholders
that's what i care about
it's really it's tremendous to see
what's happened on nasdaq
it's tremendous to see what's happening
in the esg market
and just the whole movement in diversity
equity and inclusion
well and i also i think also because
when you talk about the gold standard
and even you know why i love it at the
board level it is a board level decision
i don't want to be hired because i'm
filling a goat i want to be hired
because i'm the best and
when you look at bottom line and this is
capitalized
on you and it's all about money we know
that diversity is good for the bottom
line
we also know that when we had rules we
didn't see
any change happen when you create a gold
standard imagine a new ceo
description being we're looking for
instead of a linear analytic aggressive
assertive leader that can deliver a
great roi
imagine we're looking for an empathetic
compassionate
resilient collaborative leader that can
deliver a great roi
when you set that as the standard new
gold standard
we will start seeing the money move
we'll see the market move we'll see
the um diversity at the table move and i
think that's how we see action happen
yeah shelly it's such a good point i
think you know we all have seen the
studies that
you know women will only apply for the
job if they feel like they're 110
qualified whereas men will apply when
they're 60 qualified i think
even some of those nuances and how you
write a job description or how you
you think about the characteristics
you're looking for um can actually turn
people away
and and i think it's about and
today's workforce can walk out the door
and if you lose great human capital
right and if they don't feel
that if they look around the room and it
looks like them
or that they felt feel included that's a
real business risk
and that's something actually that the
boards are really addressing now
it's so inclusion is so fundamentally
important
and making people comfortable around the
table and giving them hope by the way
i mean shelley you've done an amazing
job giving so many women so many
women hope right hope that they're you
know that that
if for equality you've got to give
diversity
hope well i think it's hope but it's
also
visibility i it really bothers me when
i don't see women on stage speaking and
i'm like where are the women you know
because we have
hundreds of thousands of women in our
community that are unbelievable talent
you know but they're looking for the ceo
title
and i said well stop looking for ceo
title look for topic experts and you
will find
plenty of them and so for me it's about
hope
but it's also about access and
visibility
like i i love with uh you know adina
nasdaq
and you know seeing her running nasdaq
making these decisions if you can see
her you can be her
that also starts the new transformation
is just seeing all of us look at kamala
now
we have a female first vice president
we're going to have
so many more now to follow because we
just opened
the door we shattered the glass and
we're all moving on in and moving on up
but i think it's our job to shatter the
glass each and every day
right shelley so it's not just about one
one
one thing it's about constantly walking
that walk
um and i think that's how change happens
it's about finding and pulling up those
unsungs
it's about getting them um i'm working
on a whole program
to mentor new people on boards right
because again if they haven't been on a
board before
let's get them the experience let's get
them you know somebody to train them
let's let's open up those floodgates and
keep pushing
for change that's also the same
sorry sure no no let's let's just jump
in and just say let's get uncomfortable
together because
the more uncomfortable we get because
it's firsts and it's scary and all those
things
but you know what the more uncomfortable
you get you'll get comfortable
that becomes you know your new comfort
level
and all of a sudden this miraculous
change happens because we're putting
ourselves in these positions
and in these situations
one of the things i think both of you
have have done exceptionally well and i
think it's it's really important is
you've lived your values and not only in
how you've made your own career
decisions but even thinking about the
organizations you've been
you've created or you've been in charge
of
um you can really create a values-driven
organization through the financing
decisions you make through the
governance decisions you make it's sort
of at every level and and
i think sometimes that's lost in in
having a sort of a diversity and
inclusion initiative that might be owned
just by the hr team um it really needs
to be at the executive level and board
decisions and so forth and
you know hope one of the things you've
done recently um
that was in the headlines is launching a
spac
uh a qui which is the first uh fully
diverse
um spec could you talk a little bit
about one just what is a spec
for people who have heard that term a
lot in in 2020 but might not be familiar
with it
um and then a little bit of you know how
you've incorporated that focus on
diversity into the
company uh so thank you we're really
proud of aqui
and we gave it the symbol a rbg
after my hero rbg um
and it's a special purpose acquisition
corporation that is going to
merge with a company um but what makes
it different
is it's based on three very simple
pillars
first it's a fully diverse board 51
gender
51 racially diverse 100 skills diverse
we have not compromised anything to get
there we are
so incredibly proud of what we have
built
you know we're going to make an
acquisition in the data-driven consumer
tech world
but we're also going to bring d e and i
and esg to the forefront
and that's really important in creating
term value
and last but not least because it's
absolutely part of my dna
is i'm giving 10 of my founder shares
back to charity that's redistributing
equity that's the walking away walk all
the way through from the top
to the bottom in every way shape or form
so it's a
i created a vehicle that represents all
the values that i hold dear
and i know we're going to make a great
uh transaction
i think that's such a very important
message especially today on giving
tuesday as well hope so
you know we all and i have to say i mean
you
are a role model a mentor an inspiration
to all of us and
i want to add you know as you know this
show is so
short we never have enough time as well
giving tuesday for anyone
that needs um extra advice i mean hope
is amazing i am here to help in any way
reach out to us
um we are here to to help with whatever
knowledge we have whatever we can share
and as chrissy what you said before
authenticity we do live in truth we are
who we are
we bring our our truth to the table and
you can depend on
real advice even if sometimes it's hard
to take
um but it will make a big difference in
the long run so
for anyone tuning in um please reach out
if you need any help
and hope i don't know you know if you
want to jump in on that
i feel the same way i've always said i'm
always reachable
on all forms of social media i get back
to you i try to help
we have to be role models we have to you
talked about breaking the glass ceiling
it's not a one-shot deal it's it's
happening
and and it's keeping doing it and then
throwing the rope down
um chrissy it's an honor to have you
here yeah
you know and because you embody
everything that i hope
i you know i like to say what do you
want your epitaph to be and originally
for me
it was that i didn't raise sheep and
that's you know
that's the way now you know i think
mission accomplished on that one knowing
your kids
but it's not just my kids it's everybody
that i you know that i touch and
and if i can help and help this audience
in any way
let's get those questions answered don't
be afraid if you don't like to answer in
a public forum
ping us you know quietly we'll we'll
we're here to help
and i think you know your questions help
uh drive what every show um becomes so
we are listening
and we are evolving and and delivering
hopefully
on expectation and of course the
overachievers i hope we're over
delivering
uh so please send in your thoughts and
your questions and
you know the next episode will be on
microfinancing as as we talked about
today chrissy
sorry yeah no this is this is great and
thank you so much for having me um i'd
love to wrap
and kind of pulling this together we've
we've talked a lot about
um governance certainly with the nasdaq
announcement today we've talked about
giving tuesday and the importance of
mentorship
and paying it forward um hope we've
talked about financing structures and
and your recent spec um let's make this
real for people who
who are listening or watching um so
let's say i'm an employee
or an entrepreneur or aspiring
entrepreneur
what is the biggest thing each of you
would would share with them of how does
how does governance or financing or
something like that
what does that mean for someone who is
an employee or entrepreneur what should
they be thinking about
hope so i think they
they need you need to plot out your path
right so where do you want to so if
you're the employee
where do you want to go what what what
is the lane you want to go to
and then tactically think like i got up
every morning with my yellow pad my
yellow pads on my
okay tactic think about how i can plot
to get to where i need what what do i
need to check off
to get there um what do i need to build
up in terms of capital
right so am i going to be more
aggressive with my capital but
or am i going to need my capital to
invest in my own business
think through try to think about the end
point
and then dial it back and walk through
the steps
and and but don't be afraid that it
might not happen overnight
and it might not happen in a linear way
you can
zigzag so that's my advice is it's not
you know it's it's not short-termism
okay the the spec i've been working on
for six months
you know it's it was an idea and i you
know work through
every little detail of you know hold
true to what you want to accomplish
yeah and i would say on this back i mean
you've been working on it for six months
but you've been working
up to it for years and years correct and
that's the part you don't see
but then but it's hot have your goals
have had your dreams
and you know for me it's it's dream big
and and bigger and then act in the
moment and so
you know i always say have a no regret
policy i never want to look back they
should
could have so think forward and then act
in the moment and don't be afraid to zig
when others are zagging
um don't follow the path you can create
your own
and i think that your difference is your
greatest strength so don't hide it
bring that front and center with
tremendous visibility
and surround yourself with people that
are not like you
because if you were all the same you
wouldn't be necessary and so
that's my best advice so shelley adding
to that
it's i call it build your personal board
of directors chrissy
i've been a i've been a proud member of
your personal board of directors
build your board of directors keep
reaching out chrissy you
you followed and you you pursued that
relationship
don't be afraid to do that build build
the people that are going to tell you
not what you want to hear
yeah it goes both ways on that yep
chrissy let's end it
everybody on capitalize on you
and don't forget about you in the
equation
awesome absolutely chrissy thank you
shelley
gary well we missed you the afternoon
and we'll see you next time
bye